wir wissen von dem obduktionsbericht
dass man geht von einer klar eine
gewalttat aus durch gewalteinwirkung
ging oberkörper und kopf
die tat muss am samstagabend passiert
sein
am sonntag wurde die obduktion
durchgeführt
man stellt inzwischen fest dass der
familienvater nachdem er die tat
begangen hat selbstmord begangen hat
also wir sehen das haus jetzt hinter uns
das gelbe haus das schon inzwischen
anwohner und bekannte des paares blumen
hingelegt und kerzen abgestellt
niemand kann sich wirklich erklären was
da passierte es beziehungsweise was im
kopf des familienvaters hervorgegangen
ist er war beliebt man kann den gute
wein karneval aktiv
und deswegen ist der short umso tiefer
bei den anwohnern bzw
menschen die diese familie kannten sie
können dass sich das überhaupt nicht
erklären was was da letztendlich
passiert ist am samstagabend
wir hörten von einer anwohnerin dass sie
schreie gehört hat von einem kind mama
mama und die haben sich aber
letztendlich nichts dabei gedacht und
erst am sonntag beziehungsweise
samstagabend war es hier plötzlich dann
polizei vor der tür stand wurde dann
klar was hier passiert sein könnte
beziehungsweise aus welchem grund diese
streik haben gibt es dann bei den
ermittlungen der polizisten bereits
irgendwelche hinweise auf ein motiv
ja es gibt hinweise es ist die rede von
einer scheidung also von einer trennung
des paares
und das ist möglicherweise ein motiv
gewesen dafür dass der familienvater
erst mal seine frau und dann seine
zweijährige tochter erstmal umgebracht
hat und dann anschließend das leben
genommen hat wir sind bild und wir
liefert dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren